oh hi as you can see all around me it is
time for rock band 2 the sequel to
everybody's favorite four player music
game is finally available on the xbox
360 and this week I'm going to talk
about the five things that I love the
most about it then later game life
contributor and Nate Ralph is going to
be here talking about his experiences
previewing wipeout HD for PlayStation 3
coming in at number five is the brand
new song selection menu this might seem
like something small but really it's a
pretty big deal if you're playing rock
band with four people in the same room
which is everybody agrees the best way
to play rock band one it was hard to
find songs in the menu but this time you
can actually flip around like us we're
flipping around here by the letter that
song begins with we can do it by artist
we can do it by where the song
originally came from because rock band 2
has rock band two songs it has the songs
that you can download offline and it
also as the songs from rock band 1 you
can export off the disc to your xboxes
hard drive actually harmonics is that
over 500 songs are going to be available
for rock band 2 by the end of this year
but that's a lot of songs this menu
makes it a whole lot easier to navigate
through them all so when it comes time
to actually choose a song now if you
look in the lower left hand corner here
you'll see that these songs difficulty
level is actually broken down by
instrument so if you've got a guitar
player that totally knows what they're
doing but maybe a drummer that's kind of
only of middling or beginner level skill
they can see whether or not this song is
appropriate for them or what difficulty
level they should choose easy medium
hard based on what the menu actually
says so makes things a whole lot easier
when you're having a rock band party
number four is the game's new drum
trainer mode now admit it when you're
playing rock band guitar you're not
actually playing guitar you're hitting
little plastic buttons on a toy but when
you're playing drums in rock band no
you're really playing the drums and a
lot of people have started to take the
skills they've learned inside rock bands
drum mode and actually sit in front of a
real drum kit and if the that's what you
want to do
drum trainer mode is for you it's going
to teach you a whole bunch of different
actual rock beats and you can adjust the
tempo and if you can master these you're
ready to actually start a band of your
own number three on our list are the
brand new instruments now you don't need
to own the new instruments to play rock
band to your rock band one instruments
will work just fine but if you want to
upgrade there are new instruments on
shelves and they've got a variety of
improvements first of all both the
guitar and the drums are now wireless
there is nothing to come between your
drums and the TV set anymore secondly
the drum pads are now they're bouncier
they're quieter and they're also
velocity sensitive which means that
depending on how hard you hit the drum
the loudness of the sound on the TV is
going to change check this out huh huh
right now also the cake pedal on the
drums it's now reinforced with metal now
I don't know about you what mine was
starting to break right around here from
kicking it too many times this much less
likely to do so and then there's the new
guitar now the rock band two guitar not
a whole lot different about this versus
the fender stratocaster from the first
game you notice that it has a lovely
wood grain finish and apparently the
strum bar is better but that's about it
except for these two little things right
here these sensors you know how what a
pain in the neck it is to calibrate rock
band to work with your TV and get all
the timings right well all you have to
do with rock band 2 is hold this up to
your TV and it will automatically
calibrate the audio and the video for
you which is pretty cool if you ask me
coming in at number 2 is the brand-new
fully integrated Tour mode now rock band
ones gameplay was kind of disjointed you
had all the different solo modes for
single-player and you had the band mode
for multiple players and then you had
online and all three of those things
were totally separate with rock band 2
they're all fully integrated you can
start a tour by yourself you can switch
instruments in the middle of the tour as
you progress and you build your virtual
bands renowned throughout the world you
can bring in other players any time you
want and again at any time you want you
can take your band online
bring in other players from anywhere
around the world to help you and join in
but you know my number one favorite part
about brought back to is the no fail
mode rock band is a great casual game
but it's tough to get new people in it
with the difficulty curve so if you turn
on no bail boat no matter how badly you
play nobody gets a game over it's also
really good at the drunk or more if you
have someone like this in your hand so
the other day I was at a hands-on event
for sony's upcoming wipeout HD it's a
downloadable game for the ps3 it's a
reimagining really of the original wipe
out which came out in 1995 so I was
trapped in a room with about 16
journalists and gamers who were laughing
at me because I was so bad at it but you
know what it came out in 1995 I was ten
years old playing warcraft too if you're
not familiar with wipe out there are
really really fast cars blasting down
twisting tracked with weapons and
power-ups and explosions tossed in
wipeout HD takes the same formula and it
pushes it to 1080p at 60 frames per
second when you spend as much time
slammed up against the wall as I did
because you screwed up yet another turn
you really get to appreciate how
gorgeous this game is there are eight
tracks which can also be played in
Reverse so 16 total and 12 vehicles to
unlock and choose from if you enjoy
being humiliated like I didn't up to 8
players can race against each other
online or you can trash talk
face-to-face and split screen modes the
release date is set for the fall or a
few weeks from now but fans probably
won't have to wait much longer now I
thought it was pretty decent at this
whole video game thing but wipeout is
really really hard it's like something
gets faster than Mario Kart and my motor
function just shut down completely but
if you're a fan of the series or
adrenaline rushes in general you're
going to want to pick this one up
you